ce sont des scènes de chaos teles que
l'Irlande n'en avait pas connu depuis
des décennies pendant plusieurs heures
jeudi soir le centre-ville de Dublin a
été gagné par une vague de violence
inédite opposant les forces de l'ordre à
des centaines d'hémetiers d'extrême
droite selon la police tout commence en
début d'après-midi lorsqu'un homme d'une
cinquantaine d'années poignarde
brutalement CIN personnes devant une
école blessant sérieusement une femme et
une petite fille de 5 ans selon la
police rapidement interpellé l'agresseur
présumé semblerait à agit seul et sans
motif terroriste rapportent les
enquêteurs mais bien que son identité
n'ait pas été officiellement dévoilée
par la police une rumeur se répand
rapidement en ligne il s'agirait selon
certains internautes d'un migrant
algérien les premiers incidents éclatent
aux alentours de 19h des centaines
d'individus dont certains encapuchonnés
investissent les rues de la capitale en
brandissant des pancartes Irish lives
matters très vite la situation dégénère
des tirs de mortiers retentissent sur la
place de parnel Square alors qu'une
foule de jeunes drapeau irlandais autour
de la taille s'enprenent aux forces de
l'ordre et saccagent les vitrines dans
le viseur des hémetiers la politique
migratoire du gouvernement irlandais et
les média mainstream selon plusieurs
témoignages un centre de migrant aurait
également été incendié au bilan 34
arrestations et 11 voitur de police
incendié ce matin le Premier ministre
irlandais Leo varatkar dénonçait le rôle
d'élétaire des réseaux sociaux après
avoir mis en cause des fautes de troubl
plein de hainees qui font honte à
l'Irlande un avis que ne partage pas la
star irlandaise du MMA Conor McGregor
qui a apporté son soutien aux émetiers
anti-immigration nous ne perdrons plus
nos femmes et nos enfants à cause de
personnes malade et tordu qui ne devrait
même pas être en Irlande en premier
[Musique]
lieu